[Music]
we needed to be able to do our job and
we need to get the bottom of these
accusations to find out if they're true
because whether it's a prescription drug
handing out like it was candy or whether
it's intoxication or or whether it's
toxic work environment deserves a day in
court and he wants to be assumed that
the committee will give him that that's
troubling to a lot of us dr. Jackson has
had at least four independent background
investigations conducted during his time
at the White House including an FBI
investigation conducted as part of the
standard nomination vetting process
during each of those investigations dr.
Jackson received unanimous praise from
dozens of witnesses and the
investigations revealed no areas of
concern as of tonight
Ronnie Jackson is still the nominee for
Veterans Affairs Secretary and the White
House pressing to get a confirmation
process started again on Capitol Hill
let's bring in our panel charles hurt
opinion writer for The Washington Times
MOA Lee the executive director of the
Georgetown Institute of Politics and
Jonathan Swan national political
reporter for acts yes Jonathan is the
White House
you know firm in that this pushback it
seems so when they're talking publicly
behind the scenes they send the same
thing the White House is conflicted in
the sense that they almost unanimously
in fact I have yet to find anyone in
there who doesn't think he's a good man
who is being unfairly you know
allegations are out there and we don't
know if they're true or not and some of
them who've become personally very close
to him feel you know very upset to see
this happening to who they considered to
be a good man on the other side it is
very hard to find a senior White House
official who thinks that he is the right
selection for the job genuinely believes
that and believes that Trump announced
him in the in the correct way Trump
tweeted it out without any vetting
without over John Kelly's objections and
almost no one in the senior staff
thought that was great and her Sarah's
point is that he had been vetted for his
job as physician to the president very
closely because obviously interacts with
the presidential so through the FBI
checks and all that stuff
doctors the president is quite different
to running the second largest agency in
the federal government and he has no
management experience that would be
relevant for that job so that is there
soon I think they're just this is all
new information for them and they're
absorbing it they don't know what to
make of it but for the moment they're
really on a on a front foot try and do
more if there's two different sides here
one is that a white house put someone
out that perhaps you know with
allegations that are back there and they
know about and it comes out but the
other side is the Democrats in the
minority put out to the press these
allegations that they publicly say they
don't know if two are true the minority
is saying multiple individuals citing
the nickname Candyman used by the White
House staff because he would provide
whatever prescriptions they saw without
paperwork physician physician assistants
nurses have described a pattern of
handling handing out ambien to sleep
with and to probably go to wake up
without triaging patient history no
intakes no questionnaires on Air Force
One I can tell you personally I reported
I was chief White House correspondent
I took ambien from doctors on trips
overseas these are controlled substances
that were that require tracking on at
least one occasion dr. Jackson could not
be reached when needed because he was
passed out drunk in his hotel room at a
secret service going-away party Jackson
got drunk and wrecked a government
vehicle those things Jackson denies
Vietnam Lee and as far as the passing
out of ambien if unless it's something
bigger or more serious as far as the
drugs that happens all the time
yeah I think you you raise sort of two
good questions right I think Democrats
could have brought this it a different
way
right brought it to the White House said
this is what we're seeing and we're
gonna ask you about this in this you
know in a hearing they could have done
that but the second issue wouldn't have
happened had the first one not happened
first right the fact that the President
did not vet that the White House did not
vet him where they would have caught
that there were twenty allegations true
or not they would have caught it and
they would have prepped for it and they
would have addressed it on the front end
just it fits a narrative and a track
record of this White House of being less
than careful with vetting so I don't
think either side put its best foot
forward here right I think the White
House certainly caused this problem by
not doing basic vetting which was my
point in saying Charlie both sides could
do things differently the demo
reach out and say here's a word hearing
right what do you know about this or
let's move forward this hearing if if
you want to address this yeah and you
know if all these allegations or any of
these allegations are true it actually
sort of reflects more poorly over on the
previous administration than it does on
the current administration that all of
these terrible things were going on
inside the White House or on on foreign
trips under the previous in under the
previous administration that said you
know the president does have a habit of
crossing the street without looking both
ways and but it works for him and I
think that you know the accusations that
well this guy is not qualified to to run
such a large complex organization my
goodness who is the previous person in
that spot had a lot of experience with
management and he was a disaster you
know that that goes to the nature if you
ask me of the whole problem of the
federal government today is that we have
these agencies that are completely
uncovered well thing is that that's the
conversation that I think a confirmation
hearing should be about right and it's
not going to be at least for now
because of the fact that the White House
didn't vet the guy and now all these
other allegations are popping up and it
just it goes to your point right there
not looking both ways before they cross
the street and they're creating this is
not accurate I mean let's listen to the
senator tester another soundbite in his
interview about where he's laying out
these allegations he hands out
prescriptions like candy in fact in the
White House they call him the Candy Man
there were comments about him being in
the the hotel room and couldn't respond
because he had been drinking so much the
stuff we've got mostly happened during
the a years at president he's any of it
the truth the matter is is I don't think
President Obama was aware of this stuff
or he wouldn't have tolerate it if it's
true so which one is it the Obama White
House calls him the Candy Man October 16
October 17 2016 the president writes
Ronnie does a great job genuine
enthusiasm poised under pressure
incredible work ethic to follow through
ronnie continues to inspire confidence
with the carry provides to me my family
my team continue to promote ahead of
peers which one is it
you know like either they know or they
don't know I just I don't
usually try to get angry on TV but the I
actually do feel a sense of like deep
concern and anger at some of this
because I broke that stupid story on
Sunday I said they've got deep concerns
about him in the white house on the hill
his confirmations in peril and I said
there have been allegations taken to
tester the reason I wrote it that way is
not because I didn't know what the
allegations were I was given them on
Friday I knew what these allegations
were but I don't know if they're true I
have no earthly idea if they're true or
not I'm not just going to go well that's
alleged and I'm hearing that this guy
you know did all of these terrible
things and is you know XY and Z because
I have no idea if it's true or not and
like clearly neither does Jon Tester I
mean this isn't surely this is a problem
I mean the White House says they called
him the Candyman but then maybe
President Obama didn't know about it
because he wrote these glowing at the
end of his administration so there's a
disconnect here is obviously there's and
clearly yeah you know this is a guy
who's been in the Navy for a long time
has a sterling reputation has a lot at
stake and we saw that somewhat humorous
response from President Trump when he
was asked about whether he stood behind
Ronnie Jackson he said you know I don't
know that I'd go forward with it if I
were him and it was and and of course in
Washington speak everyone was like oh
he's not backing Ronnie Ronnie Jackson
exactly I said after that but but it
wasn't ours or number but if you think
about it but if you think about Donald
Trump and the way he reacts and the way
he doesn't speak Washington speak he was
just saying he was just trying to say
you know here you got this good guy and
he's getting dragged through the mud and
he looks great in a uniform and you know
I wouldn't know why it's gonna be up to
it's gonna be up to Ronnie Jackson to
decide whether or not this confirmation
goes forward that I agree with you the
first one the first near point might be
kind of light-hearted and fun but that
is a pretty clear signal what to say
only Ronnie Jackson will decide whether
or not this confirmation goes for it
that is less than a ringing endorsement
that is the president kind of putting it
out there and saying you know what you
have an exit ramp you got an exit ramp
and I'm gonna stay a little hands off on
this because none of us know what's
going on you don't know what's going on
because you
check all our leave it